but how about we we we jump over now to
uh still talking about the democrats and
how bill barr
oh gosh this was uh this was so brutal
so uh for those that missed it bill barr
testified before the house
and you know what people like to say you
know i'm biased or whatever
because i'm always ragging on democrats
yeah but i'll tell you exactly why
whenever the republicans would talk to
barr like matt gates friends and says
mr barr you know you said that
you were investigating antifa as a
domestic terrorist organization
what do you mean by that that was it and
then bill barr talks and he says well
i'm not
i didn't call them an organization i
said under certain statutes explained
everything he meant
then matt gates says can you explain you
know basically what antifa is
he's like i saw nadler jerry nadler
democrat say it was a myth
and then he asked bill bart answer the
question then bill barr answered the
question
the democrats would go bill barr you are
a stooge and a lackey for donald trump
and we all know it explain yourself
oh well i i'm reclaiming my time no
you're a lackey and everybody
and that was it yeah the whole time the
democrats were grandstanding and yelling
the funny thing is on my facebook page
people were complaining about it about
the democrats
because they wouldn't shut up and they
were like they were mad because they
were like you have to let him dig a
grave
you have to let him say something so you
can get him but the democrats were just
yelling things they read in the media
emotions emotionally triggered democrats
yelling at bill barr it was an
embarrassment
for for me as an american i mean i have
there's people all around the world that
are watching this i feel
honestly this is probably the saddest
part more people were watching that
weren't in this country than most
americans i think
i know there's a lot of americans that
were paying attention but
for every one american that was like
yeah can you imagine this there was
another person that was like i'm
watching from new zealand and that's
crazy i'm watching from
the uk and what is going on with these
democrats like i can't believe how rude
they are to him
it was it was insane me away man so i
want to show one thing before we dive
into what happened with bill barr take a
look at this
why this is a portrait of a.g
william barr from 1994. look at that
strapping young man
yeah it speaks well i don't know how
he's probably in his 50s or something
40.
middle age uh bill barr was the ag
before ain't nobody had no problems
i mean i guess there's always
controversy and criticism for various
people in various administrations
but this is a dude that served as a.g
under h.w bush retired he worked in a
private sector corporate
retired and then decided to come back
apparently he said he had no dealings or
interaction with the trump before this
he was asked to come back he said he
would
he was retired apparently very wealthy
i'm not you know i did quit google
search apparently he's got a lot of
money
okay what reason did he have to come
back and be the ag
because he probably felt the that
american needed him
wrong wrong excuse me wrong i'll tell
you exactly what happened bill barr
all of a sudden one day woke up and had
an epiphany i'm gonna be a stooge for
donald trump a man i don't talk to
that was it and then he sat by his phone
and trump called him and he goes please
trump tell me what to do i want to do
whatever
it's ridiculous bill barr
just probably wanted to clean things up
and take care of this and i said
right you catch the sarcasm and what i
was saying yeah
that as if he was actually going to just
serve as a mobster
crony for donald trump well that's what
the i don't remember which one of the
democrats straight up said to him they
were like we
he they basically called into question
his his
you know honesty and the oath that he
took and he straight up said like
how like no i'm i'm gonna choose the law
i'm gonna
i will always be on the side of the law
period and they they were just like well
that's disappointing that we can't get a
straight answer out of you
i'm gonna are you kidding me he just he
you said if he's gonna
use his position to like help advance
trump
or you know and and he was like no i'm
going to choose i'm going to always side
with the law
period and they're just they didn't get
the answer they wanted
and that was almost every interaction
absolutely they didn't get the answer
that they wanted
so let me return some of that disrespect
by showing you this tweet
hey jerry nadler you may take a nap
during a hearing but a g bar is not
allowed to get a five minute break
and in this video look you see him
dozing off look at this
i got i gotta say i have nothing but
disdain for this man
he's so real he's falling asleep you see
him drooping off
oh i'm so tired his hand is sloping and
then oop
oh wait what what's happening oh let me
pluck some something out of my ear and
then wipe it on my hand
oh what is this and then he falls asleep
again i don't know if you actually
you fell asleep again keep going right
here go go like five seconds later he
look there he is right back to sleep i
am i'm telling you i tell you what man
if you can't be awake for your job what
are you why are you doing this job
i'm not just showing this to make fun of
jerry nadler i'm doing it to show his
complete and utter disrespect for the
attorney general
for for the for the for the government
for the house for the institution
he does not care he's literally like i'm
gonna go to sleep you're absolutely
right no respect
at all he only woke up for a few seconds
to pull something out of his ear and
wipe it on his hand
so gross and then he goes right back to
sleep bill barr
asked for a recess and so this is this
is the story
he asked for a recess and for uh so
so earlier on uh jerry nadler got a car
accident very minor
but it delayed the proceeding by like an
hour so
bill barr says can we take a small
recess and nadler goes no
and he's like i waited an hour for you i
haven't had lunch yet i'd like
five minutes and then nadler's like look
we're almost done
you can find we'll we'll give you one
but we're almost done
and then no no it wasn't even it wasn't
even like that it
there was he he argued with them a
little bit longer do you really do you
really need to do this
we're almost done we're almost done and
bill barr's like
i i i'm hungry i haven't i haven't had
lunch yet
and he's like really like we're almost
done it was it was
cringy it was like and then on man and
then bill barr says
you're a real class act yeah yeah
falling so so this is
this this is what's so just awful about
this whole thing
the hearing is supposed to be about the
violence the protests the extremism
and instead you you did get the
republicans bringing it up
you end up with the democrats
grandstanding on various moralistic
issues where they want some kind of some
kind of symbolic victory by attacking
billbar
nonstop with that too it was ridiculous
bill barr was one of the smartest hires
donald trump has ever made
yep i agree he is a former he was the
former ag from back in the early 90s
he's got his portrait painted of him
no problems nobody how come
you know what like where's the
complaints from from the past work he's
done
bringing him in was clever it was smart
because
he served honorably he retired he went
to his corporate life
came back in what are you gonna say
about him all of a sudden he decided
just today to be corrupt
reclaiming my time reclaiming my time
yes
it is my time so i am reclaiming did you
hear one of one of them
one of them straight up like ridiculed
him like we don't have enough time
yet you have to respect me because i
have the time so i'm reclaiming it it's
like why are you
wasting your time saying what you just
said again just to like grill him like
oh yeah got you like shut up and get to
the point
if your time is so limited why are you
wasting it trying to lecture this man
who clearly knows more than you let me
get to the point
with this tweet here from shem horn a.g
barr quote
what makes me concerned for the country
is the first time in my memory
that the leaders of one of our great two
political parties the democratic party
are not coming out and condemning mob
violence
and the attack on federal courts
that does freak me out i agree that is
that he he's why are you not calling out
the mob violence
it's they're burning down uh m tracy
what was his name
i got tracy michael tracy yesterday we
did a um
we looked at articles that he did and he
goes across
america into all these different places
where all these
businesses have been destroyed by
rioting non-stop it hasn't
stopped for months now america is
burning down
i wanna i wanna play this clip which i
think exemplifies just how bad this is
so
so in this clip bill barr is he's being
asked about pepper balls
they're asking bill bar about clearing
protesters in front of dc
to you know because trump had a photo op
and stuff like this watch this
watch and listen to this interaction
did it decide not to play now that i
tried no it no it's not going to play
yeah it doesn't like you anymore
it's like how you tired how dare you
here we go local dispensing system
so while you in a quote said it's not
chemical you today
confirm it is chemical and you're aware
of your department's policy are you not
deposit what what policy the one i've
just
provided to you what does it say what's
the policy
well i showed it to you finally whether
or not you authorized it at the time
perhaps you weren't listening i didn't
see the policy
what was the policy in there listening
fine oh my god whether or not you
authorized use why are they treating the
attorney general like an evil
villain instead of actually asking him
questions to figure out what's going on
with these riots that are sweeping our
country
exactly and the question that she was
talking about just before this
when he said it's everything is chemical
so so when she she just like took that
one line and said see you just admitted
that it's chemicals and it's like
yes ever he's he's saying everything is
chemicals like every
all the all the pepper balls or whatever
they're they're all some
form of of chemical that's put in there
it's not just water
or then it would just be water balls i
don't know
so i'm going to give a shout out to will
chamberlain and this one man man they
will chamberlain tweeted they won't let
bill barr answer questions because they
know
he's right boom nailed it boom it's
really simple
it's really simple bill barr said since
when is it okay
to try and burn down a federal
courthouse how is
how is this okay how are you defending
that and there was not a single
democrat said it's wrong you're right
it's absolutely incorrect the problem is
they are losing on this front yep they
are the
the protests were openly supported this
is one of the
biggest you know what man i i the
democrats
have made mistake after mistake over
and over again impeachment was a mistake
now what are we seeing
mayors and and governors democrats
saying by all means go out and protest
for black lives matter during a pandemic
and they did and you know what people
supported these protests they really did
the polls most americans are like
freedom of speech
the right to peaceably assemble like
yeah why not
and then it started being shifted around
and saying well no no you're not allowed
to do everything
only we are only only the the people
that we're saying
and that's that's when people started
getting upset about it well
rightly so now that they've become riots
people are starting to recognize hey
wait a minute those democratic
politicians were marching with these
people yeah
and they've become overt riots people 30
people are dead
30. this is the most frustrating and
annoying thing to me about all of it
is when i see people going see the riots
worked
the officer has been arrested oh that's
great you crawl over 30 corpses to get
to this point where you can arrest one
guy but sure i get it and wait a minute
hold on
he was arrested before all these riots
started happening
so your whole argument is null and void
and then
they defund the police crimes skyrockets
tons of people are getting murdered now
the dnc is not going to have
you know at least 100 different police
groups they're pulling their their
officers out
what have they accomplished other than
more chaos pain and suffering
while they dance around and cheer
they've done it oh man
yeah man well in chicago they launched
two new units
there uh one is a it's called the
critical
uh incident response team specifically
for protests and riots
crime has gone down they have an
anti-crime unit
which i guess is targeting gun violence
crime has gone down
by a couple by a decent amount actually
nice well there you go so there you go
you fund the police
i tell you what man i don't understand
how people can watch you know what let
me start over
let me show you take a look at this
tweet timothy burke says
well this was remarkable and it's miss
jayapal
yelling at bill barr not asking a
question oh man
yelling at me straight up said to him
i'm i'm losing my patience
or i'm losing my temper i think is her
words i'm i'm losing my temper sir
sir i'm losing my temper it's like whoa
calm it down get your check your
emotions over at the door when you come
in here to
an official you know this is this is
official this is the government
why are you so emotional check that at
the door
in this video that is being shared and
as is very viral on the left with 2.3
million views
wow she says how were you not aware
that armed far-right man with you know
like nazi flags and confederate flags
were marching in michigan and
threatening
demanding the beheading of the governor
or whatever and bill barr tries to speak
and then she yells
she yells him down yep and a lot of
people immediately like on the right
were like
those protests for one were peaceful yep
two were on state property not federal
property
also true and that's the point being
brought up
the the feds sent out by trump are only
protecting a federal courthouse that is
under attack yep so
what i end up seeing here is an overly
emotional
variety of democrats including nadler
himself who just the other day said
antifa violence was a myth
then they play this video and he's like
you're just trying to get donald trump
reelected you have this overly emotional
response that ignores the evidence
and instead of sitting there and asking
real questions of bill barr
how about this how come how come not one
democrat said
uh attorney general barr do you believe
the use of tear gas and bean bags and
pepper balls
flashbang grenades against groups that
even when they do engage
in you know aggressive tactics and
violent tactics do you think that is
warranted
let him answer then he says yes have you
seen the photos of these individuals who
have been injured who have had gashes to
their heads who have been pelted
because the injuries you talk about with
your you know your officers are also on
innocent people who weren't engaging in
violence as well
that's that's an actual question the
democrats could have asked you're right
they don't
they simply go you're a bigot and you're
trying to get donald trump reelected
i reclaim my time and my favor my
favorite quote from him
is um this is a hearing i thought i was
the one who was supposed to be heard
he said that and i just know what they
laughing because that that that sums it
up perfectly like
well what is the point of this they they
just wanted to ridicule him they wanted
to yell out their emotions and and be
mad at him and
he's he wanted to answer the questions
he was patiently waiting there
i can't i can't believe the man's
patience yeah
well you know look he's he's 70 or
whatever
not every 70 year old's got as much
patience as that he's probably just like
well you know
been there done that just tired old man
saying yeah yeah yeah
i get it yeah maybe young whipper
snappers want to yell to get reelected i
suppose their elections are coming up in
a couple months
what's next excuse me yeah for falling
asleep no he's like as old as bill barr
he was falling asleep though who in
brooklyn is voting for nadler
i have no idea i'm just look i wouldn't
if i was still living in brooklyn
here's the challenge if you if you lived
in nadler's district
and i'm pretty sure he's in brooklyn
maybe i'm wrong and you have the choice
between him and like
aoc 2.0 it's like what do you do
move this is why i don't believe any of
the polls
so let me let me mention this real quick
because i i use the real clear politics
average for president trump's approval
rating okay to make sure i'm not just
cherry-picking
individual polls smart they
they show a poll from rasmussen a couple
days ago showing that donald trump's
approval rating was 49 and his
disapproval was 49.
they showed that for about three days in
a row and i was like that's consistent
from rasmussen
using their same methodology or finding
the same thing three times
and that was added to the real clear
politics average the next day
when rasmussen went down real clear
politics
erased the old poll with the new one
that showed it negative so that donald
trump's average approval was lower than
it should have been
and i'm like whoa whoa whoa that doesn't
make sense no just
sh show it's it's it's a lot more
complicated than just that
but it sounds to me like the methodology
for real clear politics averaging system
makes no sense
and it just makes trump look like he's
doing worse yeah
interesting yep so i don't make him look
bad i don't believe it look
rasmussen is just one poll they do daily
tracking you know they tend to favor the
president but they also were correct in
2016.
i can't tell you what's going to happen
but i just really can't believe
unless it's true that most people don't
pay attention
and if and if that's the case then then
help us
all actually no the 50 000 of you could
share
shows like this clips like this you know
our podcast
so maybe people can hear at least what
we have to say you can disagree with us
100
it's like we're like we're not like the
smartest people in the world we're just
dudes you know hanging out talking about
stuff we hear on the internet
yep but if people don't know what's
happening the conversation can't happen
yeah i had a i had a friend of mine
today a real life friend of mine
comment on one of my i was basically
live tweeting during the
the whole thing and it was it was kind
of fun i was having i was having a fun
time interacting with people because
most people were like yeah this is
ridiculous and
and one of my friends is like oh yeah
well
you know a.g bar is a complete buffoon
for a lack of of wanting to say his what
he actually said because it was much
worse and i was like are you actually
watching this
are you are you watching this right now
i don't have to watch that
to know that he blah blah blah blah blah
blah it's like
if you're not watching it how do you
know what i'm talking about how how can
you even
say and that's the problem people keep
thinking they they know
already i don't need to be let me
informed to know that my opinion is
correct i'm so
sick of that let me tell you a story
it's non-stop from today
oh goodness so there's a bunch of
propaganda coming out to counter the
narrative of the riots
and it's just that's why i'm saying man
i hate conspiracies but
it's like man it's an election year and
all of a sudden
as these riots intensify and public
opinions are swinging towards trump
a whole bunch of articles emerged saying
actually those
those black-clad individuals with
crowbars are actually white supremacists
of course in richmond it was white
supremacists pretending to be black
lives matter causing violence
a bunch of stories start popping up
saying the the right is actually much
more dangerous than the left
and then there's one antifa responsible
for zero murders in the past 25 years
somebody i know shared this and my
response was
they said something like stop you know
tell me again who the real villains are
and stop bringing this up to me because
i don't want to hear it yeah and i
responded with
a far leftist engaged in a mass shooting
in dayton a couple years ago
the reasoning for it we don't
necessarily know but he was a far
leftist
a former bernie sanders volunteer shot
a republican or as actually i think it
was a congressional baseball game
shooting steve
steve scalise okay i was a bernie
volunteer who did that
and i was like the problem with antifa
is not how many murders they commit
which sure you can go ahead and say it's
zero it's that
they're bad people they're violent and
they attack
and threaten people to get their way and
i was like
just because we know one group of people
is extremely bad because
like fringe far right doesn't mean that
antifa is good
i hope you'll be willing to keep an open
mind there's a bit of back and forth and
this person's actually
definitely like progressive leftist but
they're they're nice
i like them because we actually have
conversations we'll you know have a real
conversation about the issues
but then it's the other people who jump
in who are like
rabid and and for a lack of a better
term
where all of a sudden i used to apply to
block some of them because they're like
screaming
you know it's all like you're you're an
evil nazi and also their stupid nonsense
and i'm like bro like
we i may disagree with this other person
posting about antifa but we're actually
in conversation and finding things we
agree on
so i block some of these people
ultimately here's what happens
i said the problem that i see with
antifa is how
you have these white progressive college
kids
who grew up in like middle to upper
class neighborhoods
they show up to poor neighborhoods riot
and ransack and destroy
small businesses and i linked to michael
tracy's story
about these towns all across the country
and the next response was
michael tracy is a nazi don't read it oh
my goodness yup
where'd they get that information from
making it up michael tracy is
not he's like he's like a yeah he's a
liberal he's a liberal
uh i don't know what he is i don't want
to you know uh declare i don't know what
political positions are but he's like
he's enlightened centrist i think is
that's how you'd insult the guy
definitely but i like his work i'm not
saying it'd be disrespectful i think my
michael chase does a good job and uh
i responded with michael tracy is an is
a nazi
and then someone else finally commented
that's ridiculous that you wouldn't read
the story simply because someone said
something like that
that's insane thank you and then the
original poster was like i did read it i
couldn't find anything in there that
would make it seem like this person was
actually
a nazi it's and i'm like this is what
these extremists do
yep don't listen those words came from a
naughty person
i don't need to read your sources
because i
am vindicated in my beliefs that's
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out
on itunes and spotify and we will soon
have this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you